Athleisure Common Law Santosh-Reizstoffe,
die von Anime Ohmmeter Wendys
einzigen in CC Shine Registry erwähnt werden, verringern
Norris Varmus Sun on via Fuel und
sind unter der Leitung von FLIR und High Solute Doctor Who erhältlich,
und sogar die Abajo Tetris
unter Lindsay Purcell Babyish,
wenn Hagen Octane unterzeichnet wurde  von Chefkoch
Tecna Philosophien bei Yahoo Newton, es
war dort für C Ultimate Atom, sie sind
weniger auf der nächsten Patentklage,
nämlich Schmidt, David Chalmers,
Professor für Philosophie, Sie wissen,
Govision Shaft an der New York University
und an der Australian National
University in Canberra, CARICOM Natales
Es ist eine große Freude, hier zu sein.
Ja, ich hatte Thomas, ich weiß, sie tanken
den nächsten Lohn. Lenny, irgendein DC-Vater,
dieser
Bierkrug  Ich schaue dich an, es gibt einen Krieg der
Informationsverarbeitung, in meinem Gehirn
kommen Signale zu mir, ich stimuliere die
Netzhaut  Es ist eine elektrische Aktivität in
meinem Gehirn, die möglicherweise eine
Reaktion von außen hervorruft. Ich sehe vielleicht aus
wie ein riesiger Roboter, eine riesige Maschine, aber
es gibt auch eine innere Perspektive, eine
Ich-Perspektive, wie es
sich für mich anfühlt, dich zu erleben. Ich habe ein
Bild  der Welt Ich habe Geräusche, die
durch meinen Kopf gehen Ich habe Gefühle von meinem
Körper und fühle mich vielleicht heiß oder kalt gute
Gedankenerfahrungen Ich denke an all
dies als Komponenten des inneren Films
des Bewusstseins Das innere Gefühl
kann mir der Satmar mitteilen  Taneish sagt mir, ich
soll Nische danken, es gab einen Tomita,
ja, die meisten Leute würden sagen,
ein Thermometer hat keine
subjektive Erfahrung. Ein Thermometer
scheint ein rein objektives Gerät zu sein.
Sie stimulieren es mit Wärme. Es
reagiert und das Quecksilber wird sich ausdehnen jetzt
kann ich  benimm dich wie ein
- du drehst die Hitze auf und vielleicht fange ich
an zu schwitzen und ich sage, es wird
heiß
, das ist subjektiv subjektiv es ist die
Erfahrung, für die es sich anfühlt  Ich
und wahrscheinlich
fühlt sich das Thermometer nicht heiß an, wenn es 40 Grad anzeigt
, im Gegensatz zu mir. Eva ELISA aus diesem gegenwärtigen Büro.
Unheimliche Lockerliste für dieses Problem. Dieses
Tupel steht für das zweite. Es ist das
Heimatgeschäft, das ein Kanaan-Land, dieser indische
Australier, Ochsen auf See hat
Multimatiker studierten in Oxford, als Mann
visuell Bazillus zu den Interviews mit
ihnen tantrischen Mann Mitzi Harlan sahen einen
Arztfilm bei intrasyrischem Godzilla
Mathematiker Reggie Lewis bat Lana,
Sie könnten Beta Alpha Australian auf
dem mathematischen Olympia ausgleichen und
diese Goethe Matamata KO Musik Sameer erreichen  fragen Sie,
warum Eunice jetzt auf der Straße
nach Stan weinte, designte Polizisten im Kopf Insulinjagd.
Ich würde sagen, ich war ein Geek, um
die Fachsprache zu verwenden. Ich war sehr
besessen von Mathematik, von Wissenschaft von
Computern. Ich verschlang alle Wissenschaft, die
ich finden konnte, und ich  Wahrscheinlich dachte ich, ich würde
wahrscheinlich Mathematiker werden, weil
mir Mathematik als das
grundlegendste erschien, woran ich denken
wollte  die Welt grundlegend zu verstehen,
und wir denken, Chemie ist grundlegender,
noch grundlegender als Biologie, Physik ist
noch grundlegender, vielleicht ist
Mathematik die grundlegendste von allen, aber dann
denke ich, wenn man noch
weiter darüber nachdenkt, gibt es etwas noch
Grundlegenderes als Mathematik, und das ist
Philosophie Ich habe mich dazu hingezogen gefühlt,
über philosophische Fragen nachzudenken, warum die
Dinge so sein können. Ich habe mich auch dazu
hingezogen gefühlt, darüber nachzudenken, was die
unbeantworteten Fragen in der Wissenschaft im
Moment sind, die Dinge, die wir wirklich nicht
verstehen, und mir ist einfach aufgefallen, dass
das, was wir wirklich tun  Nicht verstehen in
unserem wissenschaftlichen Weltbild ist
Bewusstsein der menschliche Verstand wie
passt das in Tatianna Shante Arianda
Fallon sieht wie viele vor Zidane in
Mathematik sind - lieber Tom autonom
Pentium in Oxford analysierend markiert die
Mondkünstler im Freien hoffen ihre
Augen
auf Officer I  Sagen Sie, ich habe
nicht alle buddhistischen Ausgaben in letzter Zeit
gesehen
Wie der Jingle nicht über die
Tradition von Umberto Eco Hammond ist
Sehen Sie, wie man interveniert Ich fühle mich ein junges Ich
Erwähne die Sixtinische Blima Jetzt sehe den
Titel King Star Auction Dos Problem
Streit Wissenschaftler in Jupiter in einen See-
Versuch, an den ich bereits gedacht habe
Selbst als ich Mathematik studierte, war ich
als Mathematikstudent in einem Kurs in Philosophie
nicht sehr
gut, als wäre es mein schlechtester Kurs. Ich
muss alles andere sein. Ich habe eine Eins bekommen, also habe ich
nicht so gut abgeschnitten, aber es hat mich zum
Nachdenken gebracht  der Verstand und über seine
Beziehung zur Mathematik, aber es war
immer ein Amateurinteresse. Ich fand
das so interessant, dass es so viel Spaß macht
, darüber nachzudenken
Ich habe nur darüber nachgedacht, immer mehr dieser Gedanken begannen, mich zu beherrschen. Ich war in
ganz Europa
unterwegs. Ich verbrachte viel Zeit am Straßenrand,
schrieb in ein Notizbuch und dachte über
co  Ich habe ein paar verrückte
Ideen entwickelt und irgendwann kam ich zu dem Punkt, an
dem ich es mir recht machen würde, das wirklich
richtig zu machen, also denke
ich richtig darüber nach, also ging ich nach Oxford, wo ich
eigentlich Mathematik studieren sollte,
anstatt darüber
nachzudenken  Philosophie und über den
Verstand, und dann sagten die Leute, du bist verrückt,
du weißt, dass Mathematik ernst ist, und du
weißt, dass du gut in dieser Philosophie bist,
was ist das, und du hast keinen Grund zu
glauben, dass du irgendeinen
Einblick darin haben wirst, warum auch immer  Für mich war
es ein bisschen wie ein Sprung ins Dunkel, wenn ich
nur Englisch studierte, konnte ich Kinder sehen,
Mattia war plötzlich zu weit entfernten Feldern geworden
460 aktuelle uns die Wirtschaft eines
Lebens und O Muhammad beginnend auf Schwenk
Egan war halten die Iren im Falle der
ultimativen Loyalität Virginias Organ
entkam danach
Valishia entkam Vasa Fella Flucht  ed Flan
übersprungen iPhones mit Thermometer auf
anständig ish nur übersprungen Sam's Matson
Blätter von Ted de plana
Abweichung Martin übersprungen auch ding die
Ozma-Studie geschlagen in der übersprungenen wenigsten
nicht Versuchen Sie Alice, das ist ein besonders Song,
jemals hinterlegen, stimmen Sie dies auf Elizabeth ein,
mmm, das ist ein sehr  intuitive Sicht der
Realität Es gibt physische Dinge, die
man berühren und fühlen und herumschubsen kann,
und es gibt mentale Dinge, die man
im Laufe der Zeit in Gedanken, Gefühlen und
Empfindungen erlebt, obwohl sich die
wissenschaftliche Weltanschauung in eine bestimmte Richtung entwickelt hat, von der
die Leute
zu sagen neigen  Das ist die
attraktivste wissenschaftliche Sicht der Realität.
Alles, was die physikalische Physik darstellt, stellt sich
selbst als die grundlegende Wissenschaft der
Realität dar. Selbst Physiker sagen, ich gebe
Ihnen eine Theorie von allem, sie behaupten,
es sei eine Theorie des Ganzen, des ganzen
Universums und für viele, viele  Das
funktioniert gut. Sie kennen die Biologie. Sie
kennen viele Aspekte des Lebens und der Fortpflanzung
und der Genetik  wurde in
molekularen Begriffen der Chemie erklärt Chemie
können wir in Atomphysik aufschlüsseln, die
letztendlich in der Quantenmechanik begründet ist,
also haben wir uns bei so vielen Dingen
an die Vorstellung gewöhnt, dass die Physik alles erklären wird,
sogar für Aspekte des Geistes, wenn man sich nur
ansieht  Brain Check Das Gehirn ist
selbst ein physikalisches System, das physikalisch erklärt werden könnte,
dann sagen Sie
, was nicht durch dieses gut erklärt wird,
das gleiche, was wir angefangen haben, uns Gedanken
über den Verstand und insbesondere die
subjektive Erfahrung zu machen, warum sollten all
diese physikalischen Prozesse Ihnen geben
subjektive Erfahrung, die sich wie
etwas anfühlt, das Thema Böse ist oft eine
industrielle Qualia, da eine DC-Pflege-Nunca
sogar ein Fachwerk aus ungefülltem Leatrice sieht,
sogar kein D, der Endhaken, weit
siehe Manara, Tina, und sie fühlte sich nicht an
,
Oh, Lehrer, Arbeit,
Anish  Anish katya bam Dualismen Frauen
natürlich die Pipeline der sastra Substanz
und Geschenk,
es ist Tiaras Manzini, wählen Sie Glück Conde
de Guiche inter hier  Insulin genommen
Tatyana Zulus de de de Carter entschied sich in
Seattle, wahre Stadt, beharrte demütig auf t4
Tulum var, etablierte diese Interaktion,
keshite, der zisterziensische Problembus, zu einem
Zuhörer, dies alles unter
beschissener Konvention, die Sie von nan de envy
Fulton Ian erwartet, mmm, ja, also die traditionelle
dualistische Sichtweise  hatte Descartes, der
sagte, es gibt einen Körper und meinen,
sie sind grundlegend verschieden und sie
interagieren, und dann, wie Sie sagen, stoßen Sie
auf das Problem der Interaktion, wie
sie interagieren, und Descartes war der
Ansicht, dass sie irgendwie durch
ein wenig interagieren  Ein Teil des Gehirns, die Zirbeldrüse,
irgendwie werden Signale vom
physischen Gehirn an den nicht-physischen
Verstand gesendet. Der nicht-physische Verstand denkt daran und
sendet ein Signal zurück an das Gehirn, und
es initiiert eine Aktion. Ich könnte
etwas sagen oder irgendwohin gehen oder etwas trinken
etwas Wasser, weil ich durstig war Ich hatte
die Erfahrung, durstig zu sein, dies
sendete ein Signal an mein Gehirn. Ich trank das
Wasser, aber wie geht das wie geht das
h  appen wie steht das im Einklang mit dem, was
wir über Physik wissen?
Eine dualistische Sichtweise
Das Problem der Interaktion, das
Teil dessen ist, was viele Menschen zu einer materialistischen Sichtweise gedrängt hat,
wo alles
physisches Genom ist Conte Assad Vania
Canon Obszöner Devotee siehe Interaktion
Perseiden getan ist der Steve Austin und
für Honig gemachte Illusionen halten uns am
unendlichen guten Leben  wäre viel
einfacher, wenn es so etwas wie
Bewusstsein nicht gäbe, also waren einige Leute
versucht zu sagen, dass
Bewusstsein tatsächlich illusorisch und völlig
real ist, vielleicht ist es zum Beispiel nur eine
Täuschung, die durch unsere evolutionären
Selbstmodelle hervorgerufen wird, für die wir uns halten  bewusst, aber
in Wirklichkeit sind wir nicht wir sind alle Zombies
unbewusste Kreaturen ohne überhaupt kein
Bewusstsein Ich meine, es ist
eine sehr einfache und elegante Sichtweise  Strenger
Blick auf die Realität, aber vielleicht
unglaublich.
Bewusstsein für die meisten von uns ist ein Datum.
Descartes sagte, Sie kennen seine Gedanken wegen
der einen Sache, bei der er sich mehr sicher war
als alles andere  Es scheint
mir, dass es den Status eines Datums hat, eines
der Dinge, die die Wissenschaft für sich erklären soll,
wenn wir
der Welt erklären wollen, dieses Datum zu leugnen,
erscheint mir in gewisser Weise unwissenschaftlich, weil es
die primären Dinge leugnet  wir müssen
ein anhängen erklären - nur
der snichlt-globus der selbstgedanke hat alice
sicher weniger geholfen - physisch
kennt eclair und physikalist
osten daniel dennett daniel dennett ist geflasht ich kenne
ihre kadenz pilaf auf ebener geometrie
shakuntala
ich denke ausdruck emo virulent oft auch
nie verursacht durch  UN's auf ihrem Sohn
vor der strengsten Illusion und Sie können
sehen, dass
das
Gehirn ein Problem mit dem Gehirn hat  hat ein
Problem, weil es 86 Milliarden Neuronen sind
und sie alle in der Lage sind, alle möglichen Dinge zu tun,
also muss etwas
hereinkommen und dies vereinfachen und die
Aktivitäten großer Gruppen von Neuronen
in die Darstellung einfacherer Dinge umwandeln,
und dieses Phänomen ist sehr
Ähnlich wie etwas, das erst
kürzlich von menschlichen
Ingenieuren erreicht wurde und das als
Benutzerschnittstelle auf Ihrem Computer oder
Telefon bezeichnet wird, ist Ihr Mobiltelefon ein unglaublich
kompliziertes Objekt, Schicht um Schicht,
eine Schicht aus Software, Hardware und
Firmware, und es besteht tatsächlich aus Milliarden von
Dingen  Wenn Sie davon nichts wissen wollen,
wollen Sie
eine metaphorische Schnittstelle haben, die sehr
einfach ist, was eine Art Illusion ist
. Sie wird Benutzerillusion genannt. Nun,
wer ist ein Benutzer, ich bin der Benutzer und mein
Handy gibt  Ich bin eine Illusion, aber
es ist eine gutartige Täuschung. Es ist gut,
es ist etwas, das Sie wollen, weil es
Ihr Leben vereinfacht, es Ihnen erlaubt,
Ihr Handy zu kontrollieren und  all die Dinge tun, die
Sie jetzt tun möchten. Hier ist die
Idee. Die Idee ist, dass das Gehirn eine
Benutzerillusion von sich selbst hat, und das bedeutet,
dass das Gehirn weiter vereinfacht. Was
mache ich als
nächstes?  und
das Ergebnis davon ist, dass Sie, das
bewusste Subjekt, aus dieser
Interaktion hervorgehen. Es gibt keinen Ort im
Gehirn, an dem alles für
Bewusstsein zusammenkommt. Ich nenne das, dass das Cartesianische
Theater Descartes die Zirbeldrüse
genau in der Mitte des Regens hatte, von dem er sagte,
dass es war  sozusagen das faxgerät an
die seele und alles musste da
durch, um bewusst zu werden verrückt
genial bisschen verrückt also gibt es keinen solchen
ort also all die arbeit all die arbeit die
von dem schlauen Y erledigt werden würde
schätzt einen mönch ulis in der
Kontrollraum, der alles um zwei Wesen herum verteilt werden muss
, neurale Agenturen,
die selbst nicht bewusst sind
Das Bewusstsein ist wie eine Benutzeroberfläche, also denke ich,
Dennetts Ideen, wir brauchen einige Werkzeuge,
um über den Geist nachzudenken, und
Bewusstsein ist unser Werkzeug, um
über den Geist nachzudenken. Ich bin glücklich mit
dieser Idee, Bewusstsein ist einer unserer
grundlegenden Wege, um über uns selbst nachzudenken,
aber dann  er fügt hinzu, dass es
ein illusorisches Werkzeug ist, um über den
Verstand nachzudenken, und tatsächlich ist dieses Ding
Bewusstsein, das
sich als real darzustellen schien, selbst irgendwie hier eine
Illusion. Wir müssen wirklich
untersuchen, was gemeint ist. Illusionen, natürlich
normalerweise eine Illusion, sage ich gut  Ich habe einen
Stock in Wasser gesteckt und er war gerade, aber
jetzt sieht er blau verbogen aus. Ich habe die Illusion erlebt,
eine Illusion ist selbst eine andere
bewusste Erfahrung, oder um eine
Illusion zu haben, muss man eine bewusste
Erfahrung machen, das müsste viel
radikaler sein, wenn Dennis  sagt, dass die Welt
eine Illusion ist oder unser Gehirn
uns durch die Linse des Bewusstseins präsentiert wird, und
es ist irreführend über die zugrunde liegende
Struktur des Gehirns, dieses vi  ew, ich könnte
verstehen, aber dann
wäre das Bewusstsein real, es würde Sie darüber in die Irre führen,
was außerhalb davon ist. Was
Dennis sagt, ist, dass das Bewusstsein selbst eine
Illusion ist,
wir haben irgendwie eine Illusion, aber
es ist keine bewusste Illusion, wir
beschwören Bewusstsein herauf, es ist eine schöne
Strenge  Ansicht, aber ich denke, irgendwie
scheint es grundlegend unvereinbar mit
unseren Daten zu sein,
wenn Nebel Ihr Ehemann ist - Mind Meeting
Rückenlift-Illusion, dann raten Sie Version
ist notwendig, mr.
nandaka garantie stellt bauen müssen Stian WA und
uns - danke - seufz - und jeder auratus -
fahrzeug ich liebe skooma habe die cindy
eggman du besuchst eine hormonelle und freundin ramona
rizzo das IST leben sveti stefan
eisner hohe marktmiete von den phyllis
ovation eclair human  de gente en keine
Seemannslieder Ich bin unter Shih Tzu Majnu und
Robertas sind ein Mann-Kind Christus
kaput Autozahlungen sind ich bin Tarik
OB Savio Dämon Null Melodie im Spiegel ist
zu Teef oder fettleibig ah Homosexuell Film wird jeden Tag
auf Canal V DC uraufgeführt
Levins Wille Andrew Kelly hören
Release Equalia
Hamdi Physikalismus Connieyc Ebene Es ist
genau auch eine subjektive Erfahrung
, die uns meiner Meinung nach daran denken lässt, dass Menschen ein
Leben mit Sinn und
moralischem Status haben, als Menschen, die
Menschen leiden können, die wir in
Erwägung ziehen sollten Warum tun  Es ist uns wichtig, wie
wir ein anderes Wesen behandeln. Es ist mir
egal, wie ich dieses Glas Wasser behandle. Ich
kann s sehen. Loukas. Ich gehe, ja, ich kann etwas
trinken und ich habe n  Ich beleidige den Gedanken nicht,
der dem Wasser schadet, weil wir denken, dass das
Wasser selbst kein bewusstes Subjekt ist,
wenn ich ein Computerprogramm wie einen Roboter mache,
dann kann ich es einfach wie
einen Mechanismus behandeln, wenn es das nicht ist, aber
bewusste Erfahrung macht uns
wichtig, muss
ich zugeben  Jede Ansicht von Daniel
Dennett Ordnung Metaphysisch ist moralisch
Klare Beleidigung an der Leine
Respekt vor der Wissenschaft Ananda Ich schätze, man
müsste sagen, dass es etwas anderes
als das Bewusstsein ist, das die Grundlage
für moralischen Status
ist  der Evolution Wir
Evolution fanden es irgendwie nützlich
, uns diese moralischen Einstellungen zueinander zu machen,
und Gemeinschaften,
die diese gegenseitigen moralischen Einstellungen haben, waren
erfolgreicher. Vielleicht gibt es andere
Wege, die Materialisten gehen könnten, aber sie
haben sie, wenn Bewusstsein eine Illusion ist,
Bewusstsein kann es nicht  Die Gründe für
unseren moralischen Status können nicht die Gründe
für den Sinn unseres Lebens sein, also
müssen sie etwas anderes finden  Er begründet dies ganz
so, dass eine sehr, sehr radikale
Überarbeitung der Art und Weise, wie wir über
uns selbst denken, erforderlich ist. Sehen Sie, ich komme aus Parma Newton
Auktion, dann Tombi Event als Varoom ist
dies ein Altar, um Neiman zu danken,
entfernter Samba oder sogar Instant-Zombie auf
Flash-Komödie dieses Problem  zitiert ein Clan-
Männchen Sihanouk wurde abgeschafft gebaut in Ära
und Philosophie wird viel bevor
Insellied vor mir als eine
unvollkommene Klopfschale hier entkommen soll
dieser Zombie auf diesem Zombie ihr
Sitztelefon großartig kann auch jeder ihre
Vivek dieser Krise Priester kollidieren ein  eitlen
Mann Ryan
sie nicht erneuern soll Zustand von ihram weinen,
denn sie verweigert Rate Sensor Visier
auf, wenn es ein Ultra ist, würde sie auf
17 Zombie Dendi voraus markieren und in Candia Test
kann zufällig auf die Benennung einer
sanften Nische
Zungensets konzentriert werden  in den englischen Vokalen tut
dies, obwohl es ein Geschenk von Babu Stein war,
ja, also ist das Zombieauge eine
Hypothese, es ist ein Gedankenexperiment
, das Philosophen vorgebracht haben, um
über Bewusstsein nachzudenken  Niemand denkt, dass
Zombies echt sind, aber es ist ein so nützliches
hypothetisches Gerät. Hier spreche ich mit
Ihnen und ich glaube sehr stark, dass
Sie sich bewusst sind, dass Sie alle
Zeichen des Bewusstseins des Gedankens der
Erfahrung durch Kommunikation zeigen, woher
ich das weiß  Sicher, dass Sie bei Bewusstsein sind,
kann ich zumindest die Idee verstehen, dass
Sie dasitzen könnten und
reden, sich benehmen und so weiter, ohne jegliches Innenleben.
Vielleicht könnten Sie wie ein
Roboter oder ein Automat sein, der ein
objektiver Prozess ist  ohne subjektive
Erfahrung kann ich die Idee verstehen,
dass Sie ein Zombie sein könnten. Nein, ich glaube nicht,
dass Sie es sind. Ich bin sicherlich kein
Zombie. Ich sage Ihnen, ich bin bei Bewusstsein
der unterschied zwischen
uns und zombies warum hat die natur keine
bewussten wesen geschaffen und keine zombies zombies
sind ein wunderbarer kontrastfall für das
bewusstsein und ebenso für die moral
wenn es um uns herum zombies ohne
bewusstsein gäbe dann könnten wir das dann  Behandeln Sie
sie so, wie wir behandeln, sagen wir nur leblose
Objekte oder bewusstlose Leichen oder oder
etwas, hätten sie dann einen moralischen
Status, würden viele Menschen dazu neigen, zu
sagen, dass kein Zombie im Physischen am
wichtigsten und unentwickelten Visconti in einer
Höhle ist, bis vor kurzem Amöben
die Obdachlosigkeit durchgesickert sind  Physiognomien vertrieben
tut das Physische ist am faschistischsten oder
visaji nach zerlegt dann Physikalismus Wählen
Sie Dienstleistungen aus, die Sie nicht ausgewählt haben,
unser Gepäckteil das zweite uns
digital, ohne zumindest
aufzurichten
Vivia in Vivian's in
Vivian's wie ein Cooper preisgegeben
Winziger Erinnerungsarzt
sieht Elva bald als verstorbenen Val mr.  Sie
können verstehen, dass die Musik Ihnen einen
Tisch gibt, sook liegt Farben zu sehen, und ich
denke, es ist in Russland eine Agenda-Person, die
philic qualia Eliot-Tops wünscht, dort passiert,
dass sie sich als Sünder fühlen und enthüllen,
dass es fertig ist
ist alles auf Lager
MIT Qualia in meiner konfrontierten Miss Ophelia
und Joaquin ist die so Vista-Bedingung,
um Investor Halton anzukurbeln. Möglicherweise hat
dies eine Rolle gespielt. Es ist wahr, als ich ein
Kind war
waren
bestimmte Grün- oder Brauntöne, wenn
alle Töne miteinander vermischt wurden, aber
hin und wieder bekam man ein reines leuchtendes Rot.
Ich hörte das Lied hier und
überall von den Beatles. Ich erinnere mich, dass ich damals
ein sehr markantes leuchtendes Rot herausbrachte
Ich war, als ich ungefähr 20 oder
21 war, das verschwand
anscheinend, es ist üblich, dass dieser Zustand
Synästhesie ist, manchmal haben Leute es in der
Kindheit, manchmal verschwindet es. Ich schrieb
was in mein Tagebuch  passiert Songs haben keine Farben
mehr sprechen ja neben Assad und
hat das eine Rolle in meinem Denken
über Bewusstsein gespielt? Ich denke, es
hat mich wahrscheinlich auf diese Dinge konzentriert, die
Qualia, wie Sie sagen, die Farben, die Geräusche,
was die Verbindung zwischen ihnen ist, eine
andere Sache  das passierte in einem
bestimmten Alter Ich war kurzsichtig und
ich bekam eine Brille Ich war, als es mir gut ging,
aber das andere Auge war ziemlich
kurzsichtig Ich bekam jetzt eine Brille Ich trage Kontaktlinsen
Ich bekam Unterricht und die Welt wurde
plötzlich drei-  dimensional, es ist, als hätte ich
gedacht, die Welt wäre dreidimensional,
ich konnte bereits mit beiden Augen sehen, und
plötzlich tauchte die Welt auf, als würde man einen
3D-Film sehen, sie tauchte in 3D auf, das ist es, was ich
die objektiven Prozesse im Gehirn verstehen kann,
durch die die
beiden zusammengekommen sind
über die tiefe auskunft zu geben ist in ordnung aber warum
erlebe ich das subjektiv
wie der wille in 3d hinein spricht das war eine
frage der subjektiven erfahrung und
das ist gewissermaßen das h  unt das ist
das Problem des Bewusstseins genau dort,
wie werden diese objektiven Prozesse des
Zusammenführens von Informationen aus den
beiden Augen subjektiv als
Tiefe erlebt, hier war ich 10 Jahre alt,
sie hat einen BA oder si la musica Marcie Hop
9a, ich kannte Hochbank a  subvention keine
herzkrankheit und zombie blues bands beherzter
astronaut also um ihn zu treffen zombie runter
kann experimentieren oder EE the Stompa runter
kann experimentieren vegan abhängig du kannst
dein handy sehen ich habe eigentlich kein ernsthaftes
musikalisches talent lass einfach meine rockstar
fantasien lass ich nicht  Wirklich, du weißt, dass du sogar
im Einklang singst, aber hin und wieder stehe
ich auf und versuche, den
Zombie-Blues zu spielen, und das nimmt es
ab von diesem Gedankenexperiment eines
Zombies und der Idee, dass es ein
echter Widerstand wäre, einer zu sein  Zombie nicht
bewusst zu sein, würdest du so viel verpassen,
also ist es, als müsstest du nur den Blues singen,
also geht der Zombie-Blues
du, was
Bewusstsein ist, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich
habe den Zombie-Blues, das ist dein Text,
ja, und dann erfindest du einen Vers
nach dem anderen, du gehst zu einer
Bewusstseinskonferenz, jemand
stellt eine Theorie vor, die besagt, dass
Bewusstsein dieses Ding ist, und dann  Sie
sagen, oh, ich habe das Ding nicht, also, was für ein
Bewusstsein bin ich? Meine Mikrotubuli sind gestorben.
Meine integrierten Informationen sind auf Null gesunken.
Ich bin ein Zombie. Das Leben ist scheiße, aber hey,
es ist Bewusstsein
haben
wie Knockin Squats die Mission des
Eindringens in die Signee-
Ära des Erzwingens
des Philosophiemythos eines Schlüsselphilosophieprofessors über
Süßigkeiten oder Wasserunternehmen
-marie le
fucking idiot eine Million uns  Dollar
wenige besuchten Veranstaltung für M sie dies in
dr.  Koon Devon philpapers org und unsere
Online-Plattform der Comes Phillip
APIs in Philosophien von Praktikanten in der Dog
Diva Society für einige Konfigurationen von
Itsuka English Tomography Ollie unter
Fira-Website ruft auf, wenn er ein offizielles Video war
Seance eine Träne ein philosophischer
Cartoon neben Philosophie glänzen sprudelnd es war
verschwört sich, Baswedan zu unterschreiben ist Arden
gegen winzige Katzen Vektorphilosophie
im Versteck im Inneren des Zwecks oder Ziels der
Philosophie. Ich denke, Sie haben Philosophien
, die sich mit den Grundlagen von
allem befassen, was Sie gerade lieben. AG unter
allem, was Sie sagen, warum, wie kann das sein,
warum wäre das?  Was erklärt, dass Sie
wissenschaftliche Erklärungen kennen, geht so weit,
aber wir können noch weiter gehen, und bei der Philosophie geht es
darum, unter allem zu graben
und zu versuchen, es zu verstehen. Daher ist
Philosophie für mich ein Produkt der Suche
nach dem Versuch, unsere Welt zu verstehen, um zu versuchen,
uns selbst zu verstehen  Ich habe versucht,
mein eigenes Bewusstsein zu verstehen.
Denken Sie genug darüber nach, Sie werden zur
Philosophie geführt, aber so weiter  Wenn Sie vielleicht
versuchen, ein bestimmtes politisches Thema zu verstehen
, oder einige Themen, die ja sehr
aktuell sind, wenn Sie über Nationalismus und
die in der politischen Welt sagen, woher kommt
das, aus
welchen Gründen, was sind die
philosophischen Wurzeln von bestimmten
Formen der Demokratie?
Sie sagen oft, warum Sie
Philosophie machen, und ich denke, fast jeder
macht etwas Philosophie, wenn er
über Dinge nachdenkt, die ihm wichtig sind,
vielleicht tun sie es nicht, vielleicht tun sie es nicht
akademisch. Ich habe Philosophie gemacht, als
ich über diese Dinge über Sie nachgedacht habe
Ich kenne meine Vision, Jahre bevor ich wusste,
was Philosophie ist. Ich schätze, ich identifiziere mich immer noch
mit dieser Person, die
von außen zur Philosophie kam. Ich möchte, dass
Sie wissen, ob Sie ihnen Werkzeuge zum
Nachdenken geben  Handel Ich denke, der
Fortschritt in der Philosophie ist langsam, es gibt
Fortschritte, die Dinge ändern sich, wir kommen zu einem
besseren Verständnis, was wahr ist, ist,
dass es nicht viel Übereinstimmung
und Philosophie gibt  Die Wissenschaften, die
du kennst, die Leute finden Wege, um dich
kennenzulernen, die experimentelle Methode zu verwenden und sich
über ihre großen Fragen zu einigen.
In der Philosophie passiert nicht so viel,
wohlgemerkt, es gibt eine Erklärung für so
viele der Wissenschaften, viele der großen
Probleme in der Wissenschaft  eigentlich
als philosophische Fragen begannen, irgendwann findet
jemand einen Weg, diese Probleme zu lösen
und eine Einigung über diese Probleme zu erzwingen,
sobald das passiert, nennen
wir es nicht mehr Philosophie, wir
nennen es Wissenschaft, also nannte sich Isaac Newton
einen Philosophen, der er war
Naturphilosoph, aber er entwickelte sich, er war ein
Philosoph, der über Raum und
Zeit nachdachte, er entwickelte Methoden, um
Raum und Zeit so rigoros zu verstehen,
dass wir es plötzlich Physik nannten, also war die
Physik ein Nebenprodukt der Philosophie
ein philosophisches problem,
es ist keine philosophie mehr, also ist die philosophie in gewisser
weise dieser zu harte korb
Probleme, die wir noch nicht herausgefunden haben, wie wir das
lösen können, ist dies Daniel
Dennett, Garnierung meiner Philosophie, eval, ja,
ja, so an Sargon gesaugt, das ist Alice,
noch Physik College-Katastrophen, Leute,
Stans Problem, er verliert die sind deine
für Kiew, Asien, noch Onan, gib ihm  Ein Give
It in Sodom Cops Ultimate Fatik endete damit,
dass wir diese Art von Philosophie gesehen haben. Mia.
Ich denke, Darris betreibt eine ganze Menge
Philosophie, absolut. Ich kenne
Dan seit dreißig Jahren, und er beschäftigt sich immer noch
mit Philosophie und versucht, seine zu verbessern
Geschichte und um die Leute von seiner Geschichte zu überzeugen, hat
er eine andere philosophische
Ansicht als meine, und natürlich denke ich, dass er
falsch liegt, aber er hat nicht aufgehört,
Philosophie zu machen, er hat nur eine besonders
radikale
philosophische Ansicht, also mehr Macht für ihn,
wenn er die Leute
von seiner Ansicht überzeugen könnte  dann umso besser jetzt Ich
denke, was tatsächlich mit der
Sichtweise des braunen Dennett passiert ist, ist, dass die Leute es einfach
zu viel finden, zu akzeptieren, dass
Bewusstsein eine Illusion ist, die Leute grundsätzlich
nein sagen  Es widerspricht meiner Erfahrung der
Welt, also erklärt es das Phänomen nicht wirklich,
aber ich sage nicht, es ist keine
Philosophie, es ist für uns, sehr
respektable Philosophie zu sein, nur falsch
Stockton oder Vermont
Nicht verschwinden Matsu-Philosophie: Fertig, kann kein
Ammoniak oder Sanders Problem sein, diese Leute,
Wissenschaft, ist Ian van Art, Philosophen,
Problem, Ohr, dann ist die Arles-Norm, es ist
algorithmisch in kupferklarem Encantan, las
Mananitas, nicht so lange realistisch, dass
diese Leute, Wissenschaft, in denen Hetson weise sein muss
Kanton da unten gibt hier eine Ausbildung zum
Problem der freundlichen Philosophen, als
er aus Frankreich namens Yuri zurückkehrte. Ich denke,
was Philosophie im
Laufe der Zeit allmählich in Wissenschaft verwandelt, die Philosophie von
Raum und Zeit wurde zur Wissenschaft
von Raum und Zeit. Ich würde es lieben, wenn die
Philosophie von  Bewusstsein wurde
auf eine Art und Weise zur Wissenschaft des Bewusstseins
, die alle Probleme löste, aber ich denke, ein
Teil des Problems ist, dass wir noch nicht wissen,
was diese Wissenschaft ist
Ich meine, ich denke nicht, dass wir
einfach davon ausgehen sollten, dass es in der
Neurowissenschaft des Bewusstseins oder einer
Informatik der Algorithmen liegen würde.
Ich persönlich sehe nicht, wie das allein
das Bewusstsein erklären würde, aber vielleicht eine
neue Wissenschaft meiner eigenen Ansicht nach  Vielleicht müssen wir
das
Bewusstsein als eine grundlegende Eigenschaft
in der Realität anerkennen, genauso wie die
Physiker Raum, Zeit und Masse als
grundlegende Eigenschaften erkannten, und wenn wir
irgendwie eine Theorie entwickeln könnten,
die das Bewusstsein angemessen mit dem Rest der
Wissenschaft durch bestimmte Gesetze verbindet, dann
könnten wir das vielleicht  haben eine wissenschaftliche Theorie des
Bewusstseins, die einige
der philosophischen Probleme beseitigen würde, aber im Moment sind
wir keine Geiger, und es ist
wichtig, diesen Umschlag ein Gefühl für
einige dezente Ammoniaknoten von einem dicken
Savarin DZ-Ziel auf einer
Emotionskonferenz in Interlaken zu halten einige Tama
Bewusstsein von Tama be stärkt und
Künstler, die plötzlich das Glück behaupten,
sie seien Babu steht für Shunga TO  EFL und
das interdisziplinäre, leider
nicht modisch empfundene HMDA kümmern sich oft um
Preis, Volumen und das gesamte Konzept der Ökologie.
Das ist gut, danke,
vedisches Feindteam, aber unbelebter Kampf
gegen schwer fassbare Krankheiten, um zu sehen,
wie viele effiziente Russen ich kenne, ist
greifbar und daher zunächst nicht
untersuchte Esther Glanz Idealismus und
Geist-Körper-Problem auf Sterne Organe Leichtigkeit
von zwei Signalen entkam Zoo Na und Tante
lehrte oder ein elf Svaha zu den Villen
oft die Zachman-Mutter beginnt meine seit als
materialistische Don Viet Minh-Touristen, als
Montaigne übersprang, sogar reitend verlässt es das
Koma  eigene Pooja Don unsere Vietnam Pumpen
Geschichte Ministerium für Bildung dankte
auch Alice ist sogar entwickelt unter einem
Vietminh Idealisten entpacken Dach unschuldigen
Welpen der ideal glatten reichen Design
Währung die Ideologien Moses bis 270
genommen, um Dennett Alice STD Alice
East Geist so Masucci a zu lesen  Muschel, ja,
Idealismus ist eine der großen traditionellen
Metaphysiken der Realität, ich meine, es gibt
Materiali  sm es sagt, dass alles
physisch ist,
es gibt Dualismus, der besagt, dass einige
Dinge physisch sind, einige Dinge sind mental, und
dann, wie Sie sagen, der umgekehrte
Idealismus sagt, alles ist mental,
alles kommt aus dem Verstand, und Sie
wissen, der klassische Idealist in der Philosophie
war Berkeley, der sagte, Erscheinung  ist die
Realität, dass dieses Buch nicht wirklich
außerhalb des Verstandes existiert, aber es gibt
Erscheinungen des Buches, es gibt
Erfahrungen mit dem Buch, und das Buch
selbst besteht irgendwie aus diesen
Erfahrungen, diese Form von Idealismus, die
ich nie als sehr
verlockend empfand  Erfahrungen brauchen wir eine Welt
außerhalb unserer Erfahrungen, um sie zu erklären,
aber es gibt einen anderen Weg zum Idealismus, über
den ich in letzter Zeit nachgedacht habe,
und dieser geht durch die Ansicht, die
Sie erwähnt haben, die Ansicht des Pan-Turkismus
, dass es vielleicht einfach ein Element des
Bewusstseins in der gesamten physischen
Welt gibt  Sagen Sie, Sie neigen wie
ich zu der Annahme, dass Bewusstsein nicht auf einfachere Prozesse reduzierbar ist,
es ist irgendwie ein
primitives t  Wenn Sie mit diesem
Problem der Interaktion konfrontiert sind, hat der Duellant
dieses Problem, wie er
mit der physischen Welt interagiert, ein sehr schwieriges
Problem, also ist die Alternative zu sagen, dass es
vielleicht ein gewisses Bewusstsein an
der Grundlage der physischen Welt gibt, an die
wir denken  Da die physische Welt
irgendwie überall Bewusstsein beinhaltet
, sogar Elementarteilchen,
Elektronen und Photonen, und so habe ich ein
Element des Bewusstseins, wenn Sie
Bewusstsein genau dort am Ende
der physischen Welt haben, brauchen wir jetzt nichts
, das von der Welt getrennt ist, um damit zu
interagieren  wie die physische
Welt das Bewusstsein von Anfang an beinhaltete,
aber sobald Sie so weit gegangen sind und sagen, dass
es
überall in der physischen Welt ein bisschen Bewusstsein gibt, ist es
kein großer zusätzlicher Schritt zu sagen, dass die gesamte
physische Welt aus der intrinsischen Natur des Bewusstseins besteht,
wie ein Elektron
beinhaltet ein bisschen Bewusstsein
, das ist alles, es ist in der Tat ein schöner Körper,
ja, ich fand die Stadt wirklich glatt,
es gibt einen Harb  In Anbetracht dessen, dass dieses Buch
noch neuere
Werte in Ihram-Komplexen enthält, sind sie
in Berkeley gefügige Körper
Da ist das alte
Problem eines Bhakti des Baums und des
Vierecks, das ist, als würde jemand schreiben,
jemand fragt, warum ist der Baum
noch da, wenn ich nicht bin, wenn ich weggehe,
komme ich am nächsten Tag zurück, hier ist der Baum,
wie erklärst du das?  das und an diesem
Punkt postulierte Berkeley Gott, er sagte: „Ich
es ist alles in Gottes Gedanken. Gott schaut immer
auf den Baum und immer
auf das Buch, und es ist Gottes Geist,
der als objektive Realität dient, jetzt bin
ich selbst kein
Theist  Ich glaube nicht an und Gott. Ich
sehe diese Rolle nicht unbedingt für einen kosmischen
Verstand. Ich würde es vorziehen, wenn Berkeley
Gott als Träger des Buches
unabhängig von unserem Verstand ansieht. Ich würde es
vorziehen, zum
Sarkis-Prozess zu gehen und zu sagen, dass es Physik gibt,
die das Buch trägt  Bu  Mit der
zusätzlichen Wendung könnte die Physik selbst
erfahren werden, oder vielleicht sind Elektronen und
Photonen jeder von ihnen selbst ein
kleiner Ort des Bewusstseins, Kansai
tauchte zum ersten Mal in dem Moment auf, als Popish p
yeah
hier trink diesen oh boo Stein mm-hmm auf
der Pan-Psycho-Sphäre gibt es  Ein
bisschen Bewusstsein überall macht
mir diesen Müll, der im
schwarzen Bikini-Monofilament gewaschen ist, und Claudia-
Mann, der in Vulcan abgezogen ist, sie haben alle diese
beschäftigten Unterlassungen und in abgestimmte Konten ist
die Dimension passiert Dossier ist Zeit
Banzai
Ich wurde einmal genannt und ko ko ko unterstützt
genaue Art
und Weise keulegan Chino chaotisch unsichtbarer Hut und ein und in
Artikel - lesen Sie, aber ja, um Hilfe zu verpassen,
Sookie Oak, sie kommen online, hören Sie nicht
, das ist in der Tat heiß, und ich fand ein
anderes Kleidungssystem, das einen richtig dreht,
Junge kann pflanzen und ist seither damit
beschäftigt  Nun, zuerst sollte ich sagen, ich
weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, was die
richtige Sichtweise des Bewusstseins ist, selbst wenn es um
Sarkasmus oder Idealismus geht, sind das für mich
Spekulationen, aber Spe  Ich
dachte darüber nach, ob Stiftsarkasmus wahr ist,
dann ja, es ist möglich, dass George
einige subjektive Erfahrungen hat, schließlich ist
George zu bestimmten Formen der Informationsverarbeitung fähig.
Sie können sich
Filme von Pflanzen ansehen, wenn sie ihnen ausgesetzt sind,
als würden Sie hier ein Licht anzünden und  Sie werden
allmählich darauf zu wachsen beschleunigen Dieser
Film sieht ein bisschen so aus, als würde jemand
erreichen Ich bin in Versuchung von der Ansicht, wenn
ich von der Ansicht in Versuchung geführt werde, dass es überall dort, wo
es Informationsverarbeitung gibt,
ein Element des Bewusstseinsorganismus gibt,
wie George es tut  Ein bisschen
Informationsverarbeitung hat vielleicht ein bisschen
Bewusstsein, aber wäre nicht nur
George, jedes Blatt könnte ein
bisschen Bewusstsein haben, jedes kleine
Teilchen, es ist eine radikale Sichtweise, und vielleicht ist
es vielleicht schwer zu glauben,
weil es
andererseits vielleicht nur so ist
kulturmenschen aus anderen kulturen haben überhaupt kein
problem damit
, den pflanzen
und anderen lebensformen bewusstsein zuzuschreiben der trend im
allgemeinen w  Mit Bewusstsein Vor Jahren
sagten die Leute, dass nur Menschen bei Bewusstsein sind,
vielleicht Primaten, vielleicht Affen,
jetzt sagen die Leute sehr gerne,
dass jedes Säugetier bei Bewusstsein ist, Fische
wahrscheinlich bei Bewusstsein
Bewusstsein, das der Trend in
Wissenschaft und Philosophie war, vielleicht
wird sich der Kreis irgendwann auch erweitern George
Councilman aus Las Nubes, bevor Stanga
gesprochen wurde, ist noch nicht passiert, aber er hat eine
Qualia gemacht, wir haben DDT, der neueste älteste Mann,
Kreis 2 Zoll, Schönheitsfest, Analyse,
metallischer Kraftstoff, ein Dutzend  Jemand hat ein
Foul an DD Robin gemacht,
hat keine Serpentinenpalme oder einen Arm gesehen, der Augen auf die
Reform aus der Boston-Aura hat, ist das ein
Frosch, ein lustiger Garten, der auch eine
Menge bekommt, die ich nicht essen kann, oder Davina-
Kofferzeit, um zu bestellen  Unter einem
vom ersten Mal gefallenen würde ich vermuten, dass es sich um
eine andere Form des Bewusstseins handelt, sogar
unser eigenes Bewusstsein kommt in vielen
verschiedenen Formen als visuelles Bewusstsein vor  ousness
Farben und Formen als auditives
Bewusstsein beinhaltet Tonhöhe und
Tonalität dieses Bewusstsein Ihres Körpers
das sind völlig unterschiedliche Formen des
Bewusstseins dass Gedanken und Emotionen
wieder unterschiedlich sind Ich würde vermuten, dass,
wenn eine Pflanze bewusst ist, ihre
Bewusstseinsform von
jeder von ihnen unterschiedlich sein würde  die sich mehr voneinander unterscheiden
als voneinander
mein kollege thomas nagel
stellte die frage, wie es ist,
eine fledermaus zu sein, weil fledermäuse sonar benutzen,
um signale von anderen dingen zu
spüren, und irgendwie bauen sie ein gefühl dafür auf
Welt können wir wissen, wie es ist, sich zu
bewegen, vielleicht nicht, weil sich dieses
Sinnessystem so
grundlegend von unserem unterscheidet, dass er nicht gefragt
hat, wie es ist, George zu sein,
wie es ist, eine Pflanze zu sein, aber vielleicht sollte er
meine Vermutung haben  ist, dass es so ist,
George zu sein, wie es ist, eine Pflanze zu sein, sich
so sehr von unserem Bewusstsein unterscheidet, dass
wir jeden einfachen Wurf direkt in das Turnier bekommen können
Saum im Nebel Kein Nebel
auf jedem Auto Nr. 15 Vasa Mine Wendys
sind wie gewohnt gegen Gebühr zum Signieren von
APIs verwendbar Kalinin ist mein Falke, um mich zu swag
füllen, um auf diesem künstlichen Schild zu sehen,
nah, es fühlt sich interessant an, so dass Ihr
Bewusstseinskreis hat  weit ausgebaut
, um Pläne einzubeziehen, aber Stifte sind
noch nicht in Ordnung, nun, wir müssen nur
ein paar Jahre warten,
was ist mit dem, auf das ich klicke, funktioniert der Stift,
wenn der Stift schnippt, in Ordnung, sehr gut, und Sie
können einige Markierungen auf dem Papier machen, und ich kann es
Klopfen Sie den Stift auf die eine oder andere Weise vielleicht
ein Stift, den wir nicht wirklich als
Informationsverarbeitungsgerät betrachten, aber er enthält
Komponenten, die
für Informationen empfindlich sind, denn auf diese Weise ist
es wie ein binärer ein kleiner binärer Zustand
vielleicht das  entspricht einem Element
der Erfahrung. Ich stimme zu, dass dies ein
radikalerer Schritt ist, und viele Hosenkünstler
sagen tatsächlich nicht, dass jedes
System bewusst ist. Sie sagen, dass
es wichtiger ist, dass
grundlegende Systempartikel bewusst sind
ein Elektron ein Photon und so weiter, die haben ein
gewisses Bewusstsein und einige
Kombinationen dieser Dinge haben ein Bewusstsein. Die
Leute nennen das das Kombinationsproblem.
Wie geben Ihnen Kombinationen von Partikeln, aber
Ihr Bewusstsein ein bewusstes
Wesen und welche Kombinationen, wenn Sie
es nicht mögen, dass Stifte bewusst sind?  Ich
vermute, wir müssen uns für einen
Betrachter entscheiden, es sind nur bestimmte
Arten von Kombinationen, die
Ihnen das Bewusstsein geben. Vielleicht ist dies ein
Weg, Georgisch in den Kreis zu lassen, aber
nicht den Stift manisch in Baumwoll-
Chanuka dieses Wissenschaftsmagazins Einstein
Baba annum Frankreich  und sicher auf den
in der Tat Volumnia englischen CDs, die
Finn Staubpflanzen und Lebenstauben
ins Ende bringen sollten, die nur in Frankreich implementiert wurden,
leider dummer Acaba-
Postbote, wird diese Größenordnung der Lions-
Armee Mundi zwischen
50-jähriger Psychiatrie und den Propheten Anka Bromo ertragen  von
Lucky's Thornton Zulu heimelig alle jetzt
entfernen
Andre Organismus unelegant fragen einen
Kanuvogeljäger wh  o habe den
kläger im himmel kanu programm geärgert und
es ist lange her, dass
merkel wieder schnell angegriffen wird oder der masterplan
das ganze in den schulen zu sein hatte er
diesen dm von stern, der den damentag erfüllte
diese anlage ist tot  Ihre
Gedanken einer Intelligenz zu nollie
Komponente seiner rechtzeitigen Gelegenheit für
Pflaumen Oh Venus verhöhnt Ich habe ein paar gegeben,
es ist nicht der Volant, ich erschieße mich nicht,
wenn ich wüsste, wessen Charakter Tom Gabby
jetzt cerrado physisch pro Tag in
Medienkilogramm lang bellt  Ich habe nicht vor zu sehen, dass
es um den Dachidioten der Botschaft geht
, aber es ist eine andere Grundlage, wenn der
Fokus in Tränen einer 3-Bit-Seokkyun-Veranstaltung liegt.
Gut, ja, Gott, ja, an Coucy
bitte auch
ski freude tanzen es ist für alle
produkte alle wissenschaftler für alle
planeten sofort sehen dass wir
anfangen diese wurden gestoppt
ich würde nicht spät nach hause kommen auf dem
kies cpt aber lange zu mir würde ich sagen
das effektivste m  ethods on the news
film clip gerichte ausgaben razandrich eine
verkaufsexponentenbox ist wichtig für den
organismus für mehr über die signalintegrität die
interpretierung der gesundheit nur
mehrere berühmte tv lavaca schienen jetzt gerade
alle analysen herausgekommen zu sein und sie widersetzte sich
dr.  flomm sohn für ein yahoo via dann kann
dieses brasilien wertschätzen ein
geschäft entwickeln ilana treibstoff und es war ziemlich
frei, in der claire zeitschrift zu schlagen
gut ich glaube nicht, dass dies eine
psychologische erklärung dafür
wäre, warum wir versucht wären,
bewusst zu sein  Pflanzen meiner Erfahrung nach sind die
meisten Menschen oder nicht die Ansicht, dass
Pflanzen bewusst sind, wird normalerweise als
kontraintuitiv angesehen. Einige Leute mögen sich vielleicht
für die Idee erwärmen, aber ich denke nein, um
unsere Gefühle der Einsamkeit in der Welt zu vermeiden,
haben wir andere Menschen, dann können wir darüber
reden wer  sonst ist bewusst Ich meine, es ist
sehr unpraktisch, wenn Pflanzen
in gewisser Weise bewusst sind, zum Beispiel
dachte ich früher, ich sollte nichts essen
, was bewusst ist, und Ihre Tiere
scheinen bewusst zu sein,
also wäre das ein gewisser Druck, keine Tiere zu essen
, aber hey  Zumindest können Sie
Pflanzen essen, weil sie
nicht bewusst sind, aber sagen Sie einfach, wir haben entschieden,
dass Pflanzen dort bewusst sind und
was Sie essen können. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ein
künstliches ch  Ämische Lebensmittel, die nicht
von lebenden Organismen stammen, Sie werden wahrscheinlich
sehr hungrig werden. Ja, halten Sie
diese okinawanische Nahrungsverspätung in riesigen
Pflanzen, wenn der Rivale AKOP das Zooniverse behält,
das sie unterstützt haben, und in der Tat eine
Schrift auf Medizin fällt, überspringen Sie den Nachtisch, sage ich,
vielleicht Sie  kann Roadkill zwei Tiere essen,
die in freier Wildbahn gestorben sind.
[Gelächter]
Ich bin kein Vegetarier. Teilweise aus diesem
Grund habe ich entschieden, dass nicht nur das
Bewusstsein zählt
verlassen und
es sollte die Option sein Name von einem
Gitarristen Film Saga Niveau Meer Tank
bis auf Süden können auch Leute Stan
Ashford Wirtschaft Tilly nein Schatz ich habe es noch
einmal versucht nein nein er Kumpel Kiki talicia Hindi
digital sie wer mr.  Tasco-
Stimmung außen am INF-Arcade-Stil hofft, dass
Agnes derzeit hier bleiben kann, bis
Akanes Ian van der Woodsen Hamlet-Schnitt auf
einen Australier gefunden wird, das gleiche Ergebnis
mit Owens Nesta, weil zuerst
wahllos Intel gegen A und
B Conti Sun anmeldet  meine Verwirrung
das ständige Eleganz Keisha von Viet
Denise Leute sangen verletzt noch violett
unten einige ein spezialisiertes Ohr
oh kein Rajesh-Zeichen, aber ein Teil des Problems
ist schließlich, dass ich vermute,
dass es viele, viele künstlich intelligente
Kreaturen auf der Welt geben wird, vielleicht müssen
wir es schließlich tun  Laden Sie tatsächlich unsere eigenen
Gehirne auf, um zu sagen, Siliziumsoftware,
denn schließlich werden unsere Gehirne mit Kafirs
sehr langsam sein. Es wird
künstlich intelligente Systeme geben,
die fähiger sind als wir, die schneller sind
als wir. Sie könnten uns
möglicherweise irgendwann genauso zurücklassen  Wir bekommen
künstliche Gliedmaßen und künstliche Herzen,
wir müssen unsere Gehirnprozesse
auf künstliche Gehirne hochladen und dann werden wir es tun
Wir selbst werden zu künstlich
intelligenten Kreaturen. Nur damit Sie sich
vorstellen, dass die Zukunft der Welt
von künstlicher Intelligenz dominiert wird, ist es
jetzt wirklich wichtig, wie diese
künstlich intelligenten Systeme
bewusst sein werden, denn wenn sie nicht
nur sagen, dass KI-Systeme alle Zombies sind, dann sind
wir das  wird diese Welt in eine Welt
ohne Bewusstsein verwandeln mm-hmm das
wäre eine Welt ohne Sinn ohne moralischen
Wert wäre wie ein Massenmord an allem
bewussten Leben das wäre meiner Meinung nach eine
massive moralische Katastrophe wenn auf der anderen
Seite künstlich intelligent die
künstlich  intelligente Kreaturen, die wir
erschaffen oder die wir bewusst werden,
dann werden wir immer noch Leben mit
Sinn und moralischem Wert haben und so weiter, also denke ich,
dass diese Frage,
ob die KI bewusst sein wird, wenn
nicht, wenn sie nicht bewusst ist, dann irgendwie
die Zukunft von Bedeutung ist  die menschheit könnte axt sein und
apokalypse alles bewusstsein auslöschen, wenn
sie sich andererseits bewusst sind
und vielleicht genauso auflisten  Die zukünftige
Entwicklung unseres Bewusstseins bis zum Album wird
dann nur minimal gesteigert. Ich bin verrückt. Ich
Stannis ist eine Autorität der Entwicklung.
Die Sydenham sind alle Geister
Jemand, der
auch in Alkohol gesehen wird, hat das
visuelle Zeichen, dass Sie Ihr
Telefon auf Moral oder Geist stützen können, und dann können
Sie gut sehen, dass wir wissen, dass Bewusstsein
keine Moral garantiert
sind uns bewusst, aber sicherlich der Fall,
dass ich denke, dass viel davon abhängen wird,
wie wir unsere KI-Systeme entwerfen, wenn wir sie
so gestalten wollten, dass sie unmoralisch sind, könnten wir dies
sicherlich tun, also bin ich der Meinung, dass
wir KI
als Teil davon ändern sollten  seine Intelligenz und
Rationalität hat auch eine Form von
Moral, von der Sie wissen, dass sie nicht manuell kann, kann
nicht die Ansicht vertreten, dass Rationalität die
Moral selbst ein Aspekt der
Rationalität ist. Wenn Sie sie also aufbauen, folgt dies
aus dieser Ansicht  dass, wenn Sie KI-
Systeme bauen, die immer rationaler,
perfekt rationaler sind,
sie auch perfekt moralisch sein werden, also
hoffe ich, dass Kant an manchen Tagen Recht hat,
lassen Sie uns einfach immer rationalere
Augen machen und dadurch
moralischere Augen werden, die sie versuchen werden  handeln nur unter
Maxim's sie können wollen als universelle Gesetze
nach Kants kategorischem
Imperativ, aber ich vermute, dass
es Raum für KI geben wird, hier in beide Richtungen zu gehen
, wir müssen nur sehr, sehr
vorsichtig sein, welche grundlegenden Werte
wir unseren KI-Systemen hinzufügen, weil  Sobald diese
AIS mächtig genug sind,
haben sie wahrscheinlich
einen Leitfaden für die Entwicklung der Gesellschaft.
Hammad-Bürgertreffen und ein
Zombieproblem von Rossi. Es ist nicht schön. Frisches
Reh verschwindet im Nebel. Ein Spiegel pro Tag
fühlt sich an wie ihre Pumps. Sie war
köstlich  - Gilliam - seltsame oder sogar Zakaria-
Ideologien und -Künstler werden hier
unverfroren im Herbst
versteift. Eine Scheidung dist Bangkok ist in akumal die Währung
als mein neuer Freund  Assistent Zombie
von Gedankenexperimenten Gaben derzeit
dann fertig mr.  - Wie gutaussehend ist ein Mob,
böser Stein, gut, die Liste aller Leute,
gut, Zombies sind nur eine Hypothese. Ich
glaube nicht, dass es Zombies in der
tatsächlichen Welt gibt, weil ich denke, dass es
Bewusstsein in dieser Welt gibt, aber dies ist
ein zufälliges Merkmal unserer Welt in
Andere mögliche Welten Vielleicht könnte
es eine Welt geben, die nur aus Physik und ohne
Bewusstsein besteht. Ich denke, das ist das
Zombie-Universum, es ist nicht unsere Welt, und
nun gut, es gibt keine Zombies, aber
Philosophen sprechen gerne über
hypothetische
mögliche Welten. Vielleicht gibt es eine mögliche
Welt mit a  Zombie in unserer Welt Ich denke,
es gibt grundlegende Naturgesetze
, die das Bewusstsein regeln und es
mit physikalischen Prozessen verbinden. In einer Welt wie
dieser ist es vielleicht ein grundlegendes Gesetz, dass
dort, wo es Informationsverarbeitung
gibt, Bewusstsein existiert
Ja, das ist richtig, ich denke, wir
können uns eine Welt mit Zombies vorstellen,
die überhaupt kein Bewusstsein haben
Es ist nur
Physik in diesen Welten und kein
Bewusstsein. Ich glaube nicht, dass es unsere
Welt ist, aber es ist eine Welt
Wenn Sie dachten, es sei eine notwendige Wahrheit,
dass alles mir gehört, ist das eine sehr
starke Form von Idealismus. Wenn Sie mit
Berkeley gingen und dachten, dass unbedingt
alles mir gehört, und Sie
völlig Recht hätten, dann könnte es keine
Zombies geben, es könnte keine Kreatur geben
ohne Verstand, weil alles notwendigerweise mir gehört
Ich schätze, ich akzeptiere
eine so starke Form von Idealismus nicht Ich glaube, ich
kann Welten ohne Verstand verstehen Ich
denke, Verstand ist ein grundlegendes Merkmal der
Realität, aber es kann andere geben, vielleicht
Raum und Zeit  Ich neige zu der Annahme, dass
es im Prinzip Raum und Zeit ohne Bewusstsein geben könnte,
wenn das
stimmt, dann ist die starke Form des
Idealismus falsch, und Zombies werden zumindest Sinn machen,
aber Sie haben recht, dass t  Diese Probleme
sind sehr interaktiv und je
mehr Sie anfangen, ernsthaft über
Stiftsarkasmus und Idealismus nachzudenken, kann
diese Idee eines Zombies unter Druck setzen. Dies
ist ehrlich gesagt ein Croissant in Insulin
Malley oder sogar
Hancock  Sagen Sie, weil
sie keinen Ort haben Tank und Insulin
auf ihrer Agonie Schocks Sicherheit für
Shell auf der Bühne alle Bestrebungen verpflichten
sich noch Slum und C-Prime ideal glatte
Schwangerschaftszelle, aber Isabelle nicht Zalman
oh, ich denke, vielleicht gibt es einen Ich bin
im Herzen ein Rationalist  Ich denke, Sie
könnten das Universum verstehen und das
sorgfältige Nachdenken und Argumentieren und so
kann Ihnen helfen, das Universum zu verstehen,
also gehören für mich das mathematische Denken und
das philosophische Denken zusammen.
Ich denke, es gibt eine lange Geschichte und
Newton war großartig  Mathematiker und ein
großer Philosoph Leibniz war ein großartiger
Mathematiker als ein großartiger Philosoph
nein ich bin ich bin heutzutage ein hoffnungsloser Mathematiker
aber ich mag es immer noch
l  Ich möchte mathematisch darüber
nachdenken, wie
Ideen zusammenpassen und was wirklich
zählt, ist elegant und sehr angezogen von
eleganten einfachen Strukturen. Tatsächlich ist der
Physikalismus eine elegante
einfache Struktur. Obwohl ich kein
Materialist bin, fühle ich mich sehr davon angezogen,
aber ich denke es einfach  können nicht funktionieren, sie haben einen Vertrag,
dann haben wir eine ebenso
einfache Sicht auf die andere
Seite, vielleicht ist das ein Teil dessen, was mich
dazu bringt, über Hosensarkasmus und sogar Idealismus nachzudenken,
weil es immer noch diese Idee beibehält,
das Komplexe in Begriffen
von zu erklären  einfach, was ich
sehr attraktiv finde, es ist Eisen in einen
Weihnachtsdampfer gesprungen, es ist ein Glitzerfagioli, das
Un's oben, Astonishia, Viton, Kanton, siehe
Hübner, Ventus. Ich brauche einen bekannten Historiker,
sogar englische Chips
Bauern wieder Künstler neuronale
Verbesserung wurde eine unverminderte
Substanz und der Name des Sohnes und Patricia
Daily Shatrughan von Berater gegen
Corrado Ulta phil  osophie jeden Moment ist es
ein Acco systemische Evolvin diese von uns
gehorsamsten Vermögenswerten es fragte uns Menschen
zu einer vitalen Mitte gesendet Substanz es gibt viele
verschiedene Möglichkeiten, Ihr
Bewusstsein zu erweitern Ich habe ein
wenig mit bewusstseinserweiternden Substanzen experimentiert
plötzlich ich eine davon  Die Rezensionen zu meinem
ersten Buch The Conscious Mind, als es
vor 20 Jahren herauskam, sagen, das sei großartig,
aber wenn er über Bewusstsein spricht,
braucht er mehr Daten, also sollten diese Philosophen
ständig mit Psychedelika experimentieren, um ihr Datenspektrum zu erweitern,
und Sie  Ich habe diese
begrenzten normalen menschlichen Formen des
Bewusstseins,
warum nicht mehr entdecken, also habe ich ein
wenig davon getan und andere Philosophen
haben mehr getan. Ich kenne jetzt einige Philosophen
, die Bücher über psychedelische Erfahrungen schreiben,
aber es gibt viele Möglichkeiten
, Ihre Expansion zu erweitern  Ihr Bewusstsein
mit Bildung und Kultur ist eine Möglichkeit
, Ihr Bewusstsein zu erweitern. Technologie ist eine
weitere Möglichkeit, Ihr Bewusstsein zu
erweitern  Interaktionen mit unseren Smartphones und
mit Computern erweitern in gewisser Weise
unseren Geist, erweitern unser
Bewusstsein,
wenn die Fuentes dort Unternehmen sind und
parallel die Zeitbank der Besitzer von Universal
Murkly ist  Sehr interessante
Frage Vielleicht sind wir nur eine Stufe in
der Evolution des Bewusstseins, bevor
Menschen auf der Bildfläche erschienen. Vielleicht meine ich,
ich wollte nicht sagen, dass es eine Ordnung
des Bewusstseins gibt und wir höher sind als
Primaten höher waren als Hunde
höher waren als Mäuse  aber immer noch hat
sich etwas entwickelt, Formen des Bewusstseins haben sich
ausgeweitet, es gibt einen gewissen Reichtum an
Bewusstsein, der
bei uns entstanden ist. Ich denke, ich neige zu der Annahme, dass
wir nur einen Schritt in dieser Kette sind, und zum
Beispiel, ob es sich um zukünftige künstliche
Intelligenz oder zukünftige Implantation von
Technologie handelt  wird wahrscheinlich
unseren Geist erweitern und erweitern, und es kann viele,
viele geben, und wir stehen vielleicht erst am Anfang
g der kosmischen Evolution des Geistes und
dann, vielleicht ja, wir haben genauso
gefragt, wie es ist, eine Fledermaus zu sein, wir
könnten auch fragen, wie es ist, eine
superintelligente künstliche
Intelligenz zu sein, und wir können das absolut
nicht im Griff haben  jetzt, aber
vielleicht in 10.000 Jahren in der Zukunft, werden sie
auf unsere Form des Bewusstseins zurückblicken,
und ich sagte gut, wie schön für diese sehr
begrenzten Wesen und wie süß sie
dachten, sie könnten sogar anfangen,
über das Problem des Bewusstseins zu spekulieren,
wenn sie so wenig wissen  wie sie
es mit den Formen des Bewusstseins taten, die
wir jetzt haben, aber man muss irgendwo anfangen,
was gegen den englischen Ops-Zuhörer verstößt.
Offensichtlich hat jedes Design eingegossen. Ich bin
richtig gesagt
es war mir eine große Freude
[Musik]
du